on a des vidéos est-ce que tu connais
quelqu'un autour de toi tu aimerais de
venerque l'assaut sur la capitale soir
[Rires]
est ce que vous avez trouvé
mais ces mini à la salle ultra s'arrête
alors on ac 2e pas de derby county qui
céda doubs alors indices si tu devais
partir en vacances cuir est plutôt au
pays des koalas et des kangourous ou
alors dans la ville de la bouillabaisse
et de la bonne mère or à l'heure qu'il
est c'est une très bonne amie à vous
c'est ma cuisine je sais votre cousine
ouais même sur les trucs qu'on n'est pas
[Applaudissements]
je les connais envahi mon frère mais
c'est qu'il sait qu'il avait écrit je
sais papa maxi d'annexer la maison mais
je la connais je les connais mon père
appelait koné et phénomène mon père
m'avait dit mon faire cesser les
charlots c'est le bouddha répond pas là
c'est des champions du monde ils sont
récupérés lacazette c'est qui ça et
c'est pour qui c'est pas mexès-rami
c'est votre cousine
ça fait plaisir de la voir même pas
écoutés mais pas écouter ce que ça
changera pas de ce qu'on fait dans
l'émission